hila Coase true single molecule
sequencing has become a reality let's
take a closer look at how it works
sample preparation is simple and can be
performed by a single person in less
than a day in a tube or microplate a DNA
sample is cut into short strands of 100
to 200 nucleotides in length a poly a
universal priming sequence is added to
the 3 prime end of each DNA strand and
each strand is labeled with the addition
of a fluorescent adenosine nucleotide
these labelled strands will serve as
templates for the single molecule
sequencing chemistry the DNA strands are
then hybridized to the helical flow cell
which contains billions of ala goaty
Universal capture sites that are
immobilized onto the flow cell surface
each individual template that hybridizes
to the flow cell surface will generate
its own sequencing reaction because the
HeLa scoped sequencer detects single
molecules the templates can be packed at
a very high density about 100 million
templates per square centimetre or
billions per run once the samples have
been hybridized to the flow cell surface
they are loaded into the instrument
a laser then illuminates the surface of
the flow cell showing the location of
each fluorescently labelled template a
CCD camera produces a map of the
templates on the flow cell surface the
instrument takes many images in a
stepwise pattern across the flow cell
after the templates have been imaged the
template label is cleaved and washed
away the sequencing reaction begins by
introducing a DNA polymerase and a
fluorescently labeled nucleotide in this
case adenosine the ala goatee capture
sites serve as sequencing primers for
the TS MS process DNA polymerase
catalyzes the addition of the labeled
adenosine to the primers in a template
directed manner a wash step removes the
polymerase and any unincorporated
nucleotides the billions of single
molecule templates that have
incorporated an A are then visualized by
illuminating and imaging the entire flow
cell surface after imaging a cleavage
step removes the fluorescent labels the
process continues through each of the
remaining bases C G and T
and repeats until the desired read
length is achieved sequence information
is collected with each new base addition
billions of strands at a time
unlike amplification based sequencing
technologies the TSM s process is
asynchronous every strand is unique and
sequenced independently the first
generation HeLa scoped single molecule
sequencer will sequence a billion bases
per day a throughput unmatched by any
other technology but that's only the
beginning the instrument is designed to
achieve a throughput up to a billion
bases per hour and that's how HeLa Coase
is going to deliver that one day
thousand-dollar genome